rechercher des solutions pour intégrer
de l'intelligence artificielle dans
l'activité des entreprises
c'est l'objectif de ce nouveau centre de
recherche et développement 10 bm france
implantée sur le cluster paris saclay le
géant américain de l'informatique
travaille notamment avec le groupe
guerbet spécialiste de l'imagerie
médicale la collaboration avec d'autres
entreprises
un axe stratégique pour ibm france or
l'idée c'est travailler sur l'imagerie
médicale et de commencer à construire
des outils qui vont permettre aux
radiologues de faciliter sa tâche dans
la détection la caractérisation des
cancers nous trouve une silicon valley à
la française où il ya toutes les
entreprises qui vont bien et donc en
fait beaucoup des projets à eux qui sont
à venir sont à inventer
mais le fait qu'on soit là on va pouvoir
tisser les liens qui vont bien pour
pouvoir créer justement cette valeur est
aussi créé les compétences de demain
parce qu en ouvrant nos laboratoires en
ouvrant nos portes en travaillant avec
l'écosystème et dans vos vies permettre
à certains de faire des choses qui ne
pouvaient pas faire auparavant dans cet
écosystème économique il ya aussi
l'université de paris saclay elle
propose déjà des filières sur
l'intelligence artificielle
cette nouvelle implantation va renforcer
la collaboration avec ibm france et la
mobilité des étudiants vers la recherche
en entreprise
avec aussi un impact sur les étudiants
non seulement à travers les stages à
travers l'apprentissage mais aussi la
sensibilisation à l'entrepreneuriat
on est de toute façon sur une dynamique
de réflexion pour la formation de
l'intelligence artificielle et c'est
clair que le partenariat avec ibm va
nous aider à développer de nouvelles
filières et de nouvelles orientations
doigt pour des raisons économiques pour
des 1 souveraine et pour des raisons de
modèle de société permettent en france
d'émerger les champions de
l'intelligence artificielle que ce soit
dans l'offre ont la capacité à
développer de l'intelligence
artificielle mais aussi dans les usages
le gouvernement prévoit d'investir 1 5
milliard d'euros dans l'intelligence
artificielle sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat
de son côté ibm france construit
actuellement un autre bâtiment pouvant
accueillir 350 personnes